I can like tell in a guy's voice if he
didn't have a mom in the home I don't
know how to describe it but I'm sorry
no no I'm serious like like you can just
tell in the way they interact with you
it's it's really weird I don't know what
would you say is like more feminine or
like slightly yeah or it's like they
almost like
it's almost okay I feel like when you
look at a kid that's a boy right it's
like they're naturally the things men
should be like they speak their mind
they like play they're like like all
that stuff and it's like you see that 22
years later you can just see they've
been like feminized and it's like
they're almost like programmed to think
differently because like women raise
them or telling them what to say and
what to think
that's the same sorry but you said it's
the same with if uh the father's in the
life but it's not in the home do you
still see that
um it depends I think like if it's 50 50
custody potentially but if the mom like
I know a couple where like I can't tell
but they're usually older right yeah I'm
saying but in a caveat to that as well
as that when it comes to single parent
Homes single parent homes with a father
is the single parent the kids tend to
turn out better than when the the mother
is a single parent
do you know why that is I don't know why
that is
it's after the age of like women raise
better kids up to the age of like seven
where men raise better kids after and
it's because
um I I mean they think it's because men
are more consistent where women are more
emotional so it's like confusing for a
kid like what's right what's wrong when
mom's on her period once a month and
like today like this is really wrong but
last week is kind of wrong you know
um and the other thing is that men are
better with money financially so yeah uh
no I mean majority the majority like
like women make 70 to 80 percent
consumer buying decisions we also spend
more even though we make less okay
and so like I own two phones you can see
my debt I'm gonna name it on Sheen okay
like she needs to chill out
so I have a question for the women
how much does your submission cost
oh what do you mean like okay so when I
I use this example when I say submission
so he says babe trust me quit your job
gained that much trust for them I think
I would be able to do it 15 000 pounds a
year is what he makes no okay
okay 20 000 pounds a year I don't think
it's even there's there's a that means
there is a prize there is a surprise to
me like
emotional
security you know I really need that
moment
okay so emotional security but he earns
30k
women leave 70 to 80 of the time because
90 of their college educated like men
really don't leave because I mean we're
literally paid to leave
okay 50 000 pounds
sixty thousand pounds right so I can't
work at all like can I have a little
side hustle no no that's not the point
like you you I didn't tell you what he's
gonna have you do maybe you work for him
I don't know he just okay he just says
quit your job trust me
okay I think fifty thousand I have a
plan I think fifty thousand fifty
thousand yeah so if you guys make it
this is me
do you think make fifty thousand
like six percent no it's probably higher
it's not high but it's hiding that it
must be like 50. actually I don't I
would have thought it would be quite
fairly High I think the higher end in
the UK is that the average income in the
UK I think is between 24 and 28 000 a
year that's the average so 40 of Mary 10
make about 70k yeah and that's the
higher end so that's that would be
higher value in yeah so maybe it's like
15.
it says six percent of the UK population
earn more than fifty thousand dollars oh
my God
I mean it might be different in London
but it says six percent of the UK
population earn more than 50 000 pounds
a year it only matter in London because
like five percent of that is in London
yeah yeah
right in this room I mean let me do you
do it so everyone go around say what
your submission costs I'm gonna look
be honest as well
um
[Music]
he will need to earn
100 and something okay and and I know it
sounds like a wild number but the only
reason why I'm saying that is I'm
thinking about what I know costs are
right now
and I'm thinking if he could earn that
and even whatever he's got planned
doesn't necessarily go to plan I know
we're still okay
so yeah okay what do you think
um I think for me like he would have to
earn I don't know like probably like
over 100k like and I would have to get
money since my bank account like every
month like I would have to be getting
paid like I know you're asking questions
can I just ask her a question so if he
gave you 500 pounds a month 500 okay so
I had this conversation with someone
right he's paying for everything okay
you have no bills okay you have no
nothing your phone bill every
electricity everything and he gives you
500 pounds to spend on whatever you want
every month is that enough how much is
he making that's not your business yes
no no I don't think a woman needs to
know how much amount earns because we
like to spend their money for them
before they've made it so I don't think
we need to but that's why she's smiling
it's like yeah yeah I'm gonna get that
money
and your bills are paid like so what you
used to spend on by yourself or bills
used to you don't need to pay for that
anymore you've now got 500 pounds to do
your nails anything you want to do 500
pounds is that okay
I mean if that's all he can give that's
all he chosen to give he's not about Pam
he's just chosen to give you 500. okay
that I have so many questions but I mean
like
it's black and white if that's the
minimum like sorry if that's like all he
can give then of course like I'm more
than happy to accept that because I'm
swimming with our words that's it's not
about whether it's all he can give he
has chosen to give you 500. all your
bills are paid it's not about chosen or
all he can afford it's not about what he
can afford he said you are getting 500
pounds
why don't you say that's nice of him
that is nice of him you're not happy
about it but like I want to know more
context about the situation
the whole thing of you whether you're
satisfied at 500 pounds
if that was all he could give it sounds
like you'd be okay yeah if he could give
you 5 000 it sounds like you'd be pissed
um
but you chose the 500.
I would like
the thing is as well like I would look
at my own circumstances while like how
much do I actually need you know like do
I need more than 500 because if I do
then I would have to have well you don't
need you in terms of everything is
painful everything's paid this is just
this is what would you need it for this
is your play money this is
Monopoly money lashes Nails yeah I'll be
fine with 500 of course okay but why was
it so hard for you to because like
I don't know like for me I just feel
like if he's earning like a lot of money
and we're a partnership like we're
building
you know things together family together
a house together then why would he want
to limit me like I would like if if it
was the other way around I would always
give more I would always
just about to say like why do you you
part of you guys building a house
together and whatever has not got
anything to do with you financially your
part is keeping the home safe and secure
so so long if that's our agreement
between us then yeah but as soon as so
baby as soon as you stop working and
stuff
Financial was not part of your group you
you are yeah I'm saying so why is it I
just feel like us women
like I'm I as well I'm trying to unlearn
a lot of bad habits of and I think it's
because we've been given so much power
in terms of the jobs that we have access
to so sometimes the jobs we have we
bring that mentality home and how we
communicate with men and all of that you
have to remember they're paying you so
they deal with our [ __ ] but a man
has chosen to marry you so I don't have
to deal with this even though I've asked
you to marry me I I decided to ask you I
didn't have to ask you the main thing
about that is that
you will go into work every day if even
though you hate your job and you won't
talk back to your boss yeah and in that
same scenario that we just painted where
your man's giving you free money Etc
you're still going to come back to your
man and try and cause trouble at home
that makes zero sense to me
in that and that's it that situation
my my
um one little thing that I would say is
that it's not the 500 that is an issue
for me it's
um
the trust I feel like the trust should
go both ways so for me for me you
capping me at 500 is kind of like one
I'm a dependent you don't really trust
your children with money like that so
you're it's almost like I'm a dependent
I'm a child
um and secondly
for me as I said I feel like if you just
if your card's just staying just like
babe like do the shopping or whatever
you should trust me yeah as your wife
that I'm not going to be Reckless with
your money but it's for me I don't know
it maybe it's a me problem how it'll
make me feel yes not necessarily that
it's the cap that how it would make me
feel but also like you also don't you
also don't know why he's doing it yeah
like like saving for a house or
something but the whole point of
submission is like you trust him yeah
that's why Nations right yeah but that's
why I said it might be a real problem
that how how it makes me feel I see I
don't think it's a thing where like I
don't disagree with what you're saying
but I think we're all very intelligent
adults yeah and we just quoted a stat
that women own two-thirds of consumer
I think women are children actually
that's controversial
you're just trying to play the best
well you have to expand on that one yeah
if we know the facts as to how women
make consumer decisions then again and
you trust your man doesn't it just
doesn't it make sense that you know if
left your own devices over time you'll
become frivolous with that money yeah to
the situation I think it may be
different it may be subjective because I
handle all the bills and stuff in my
house not that I pay for it but my
husband I think I'm better with in terms
of
organization I don't know I don't think
I'm the exception I think that might be
a quality of a wife no I think like a
lot of girls are better at like
accounting yeah
you have like a whole spreadsheet you
know I mean we have the incomings and
I'm much more better with budgeting and
all that stuff yeah but I think men like
just don't make impulse decisions yeah
yeah like we'll see like a cute outfit
we'll be like buy it don't even look at
it yeah okay
um you um feeling that way about the 500
so if he had left you with his card
unlimited you probably will still spend
just that 500 anyway so is it not more I
might not I might not even spend the
thing exactly but that's foreign
it has like an underlying feeling of
like control so I might spend 100 I
might spend 50 years
not controlled well not for me well I
think as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible